chaque fois je me fais éclater la main
et facture ouverte alors je me suis mis
là en presse et pour terminer une
facture à la mâchoire
ce personnage célèbre qui se cache
derrière un masque de fer c'est Walter
Spanghero le joueur le plus cabossé du
rugby français 16 ans de compétition en
division nationale et des fractures un
peu partout des fractures que Walter
Spanghero exhibe fièrement comme un
ancien combattant montre ses décorations
à l'heure de la revue de détail
j'ai commencé à me casser c'est le cas
de la ville en 66 contre Grenoble
facture à calculer dépassement bêtement
chez moi je suis monté dans un camion
alors que j'avais le bras en échappe et
la clavicule cassée est déplacée j'ai
bougé quand même fait un geste et la
clavicule
ce que j'ai fait je me suis remis en
passe tout seul et je suis resté comme
ça
pendant 10 jours sans aller voir le
docteur quand je suis venu à la hauteur
qui m'a passé à la radio il m'a dit mais
qu'est-ce que c'est il me dit qu'est-ce
qu'il y a mais c'est passé il faut le
casser
j'explique comment ça s'est passé et mon
but tu es gonflé quand même tout de
suite
là je suis obligé de jouer dans 15 jours
et je vais jouer dans 15 jours et sa
tenue de plus à tiens une jolie bosse là
qui dépasse mais esthétique on s'en fout
dans ce jeu et l'essentiel c'est que ça
tienne j'ai continué par le nez en 72 en
Australie et puis j'ai eu des côtes
cassées un peu partout sur l'arrière sur
le devant
celle aussi qui m'empêche 22 jouer à
l'actuel parce que c'est sur le devant
et c'est très long à guérir et en plus
il y a pas de masse musculaire pour les
tenir puis j'ai vu des factures à la
main recevez
de touche
perron l'international
bouger il m'avait j'avais mal à il
m'avait fait très mal là c'est pas
intense
et subitement j'ai
eu un ballon et je me le vois ce pédon
comme un département
je te bouger un peu j'arrive plein faire
plein de fer on va où je me baisse pour
pour le faire exploser j'accroche ça
chaque fois j'en fais éclater la main
sans facture le sol naturel s'infacture
et facture ouverte je me suis mis en
place
et je suis sorti vers le vol au Seigneur
et le Seigneur il me dit Oh salut
je suis resté là aussi 20 jours sans
jouer et j'ai eu j'ai eu toutes ces mal
là ça me bouger la peur c'est que la
main est encore déformé et ça me fait ça
m'a fait souffrir et pour terminer une
facture à la mâchoire contre Biarritz
match mené 74-0 donc le match était
terminé depuis longtemps et
accidentellement sur un championnat
d'adversaire je me suis facturé la
mâchoire ici je pense que c'est tout
viens quand vous constatez les dégâts
vous avez l'impression d'être un ancien
combattant
non pas du tout non là la première vue
c'est impressionnant mais je me porte à
merveille et je pense que pour l'instant
je peux encore le servir et justement je
me suis posé la question lorsque le jour
David avant le mariage Toby a dit à ma
femme mais
qu'est-ce que vous épousez là il est
cassé partout cet homme je me suis
commencé à se poser des questions et
dans les salles de plus près
[Musique]